The Twilight Saga New Moon because what
would the world be if someone didn't
take the eternal myth of vampires versus
werewolves and turn it into a crossbreed
of underworld Meets The OC
the answer better in reality I should
love Twilight Twilight staking it back
for the skinny pale white guys but after
two hours of feeling my sperm die
minute-by-minute yeah I just don't now
let's cut the and be clear here
the Twilight movies are not vampire
movies they're teen dramas involving a
love triangle between an overzealous
best friend with anger issues and hairy
palms an overly dramatic girl and an
emotionally closed off boyfriend so it's
kind of like every other teen drama
you've ever seen so make no mistake it's
not actually a vampire movie I was at
the store and I saw Twilight on a shelf
alongside vampire movies like from dusk
till dawn The Lost Boys and underworld
saying that Twilight is anything like
these movies is like saying that Rudolph
the red-nosed reindeer is like Lord of
the Rings because it has elves so don't
be fooled guys The Twilight Saga as a
whole is ultimately nano - I know set in
the Northwest
it's True Blood without the tits yes
let's face it no matter how they try to
cut together a trailer to make it look
epic enough for us guys to enjoy the
Twilight movies are just not meant for
us it's ultimately porn for women it
absolutely is if you think about it it's
corny it has laughable dialogue and for
reasons unknown to us it unquestionably
turns on his target audience porn for
women or anyone who watches Glee New
Moon is your basic love triangle middle
school that you've seen a
hundred times before
only when you saw it before it wasn't
needlessly overhyped like it is now you
have mr. Metro sparkly skin on one side
you have mr. friendzone on the other who
starts having thoughts about Bella about
the time he starts getting hair in funny
places and howling at the moon the whole
thing just doesn't feel anything more
than useless even at the end of the
movie when they throw in a little tussle
between Edward and some of the Volturi
because at a point during the fight you
start thinking to yourself you've seen
vampires fight before all badass like
with a sword and it was called blade if
New Moon has taught us anything it's
taught us that doubling the budget from
the first movie doesn't make the acting
any better being a werewolf still does
not get you out of the friendzone and no
matter how many vampires werewolves or
psychics you throw on the screen it's
still just overly dramatic high school
there is just no way to make any high
school drama monumental at all unless it
involves Lord Voldemort and I don't
really see how Edward and Bella connect
like at all they just never seem happy
everything is just so serious all the
time
he seems still perplexed 24/7 he could
be seeing anything it looks like it's
the most important thing he's ever
thought he's ever said this is the last
time you'll ever see me I'll have a
number seven with a coke and large fries
please
he has no personality I just I don't see
it and not only did I not buy the love
between Teen Wolf and Bella Bella and
Edward Edward and his pair but I just
didn't care by the end of the movie you
don't care if everyone lives happily
ever after or they all end up graduating
high school where they don't think about
each other until the 10-year reunion
rubella packs on about 98 pounds Edward
becomes a divorced struggling artist and
Teen Wolf becomes a hairy back bald
mechanic still sporting his letterman
jacket working at his family owned Auto
wrecking yard Hatcher does a reality
right there you just don't care in the
end you're just left with that feeling
you get when you get a cat's game in
tic-tac-toe you're just like well that
was remarkably pointless so ladies if
the movie is anything like the book we
guys yeah we still don't get the point
but if you're going to subject your
boyfriend date or any guy to this
whatsoever please be sure to make it up
to him like big-time because for us the
Twilight movies are like going to the
dentist
if the dentist happens to be a cross
between Michael J Fox and Ray Charles
with no anesthetic and to you guys out
there with girlfriends yeah good luck
dodging this bullet because it's coming
I'm sorry